c'est l'heure FTT au sommet bienvenue à
l'âge vertigineux desnudo tête olympique
slogan stupide maître de cérémonie premier public
et moi le téléphone lhasa loja de risa ne le
connais pas comme un étage maintenant passons
directement au sketch que j'ai amené les bébés
dans un  monde de la fosse et s'il avait pu
parler bientôt dans une autre salle de livrée a
ce que j'ai demandé pour savoir qui j'ai frappé la
raison de cela la mère est un imbécile
excusez-moi junkie qui a amené le pire
des anciens dans une nouvelle vie fuyez mais
ceci  l'emballement a été absent aujourd'hui de
toute façon poussez le spectacle me
montrer un chemin pour un consommateur de base
sûr que la course dans la première victoire parce qu'il a été
aspiré par les croyants et les
croyants le traversera, puis même parler à un
journal de danse ne peut pas avoir  rien de tout cela ne
dit ce que ce jour
mon pote alors portez mon témoignage j'aime juste aimer
intelligent tu ne veux pas le porter pas besoin
de poser cette question ne mentionne pas tu
sais quoi Lance désolé maintenant je connais une fantaisie
nancy mais la déclaration elle  a fait tenir un
avion au loin une erreur  déjà pris un coup
dans une chaudière au cratère ont été baignés dans
le gamin juste de la merde et en cours de mode
un jour maintenant assez de règles de turok permettent le
seul design restant pour un proche moi pour nous
josh s'est converti en rien d'autre que le
lavage de pierre saute maintenant  une confiance illimitée à
propos de nous tous, ne le sautez pas si
vous voulez le décrire comme une
action qu'est-ce que cela mène à des emplois que
je suis certaines personnes disent ce que j'ai fait pendant
toutes mes années mais j'ai montré mon travail acharné  J'ai
entendu dire que bousculer est pire que pousser, mais
je sais plutôt ce qui été et moi parce
que c'est une blague,
croyez-le ou non, la plate-forme est
plus que de la charité, mais les jouets ne
coïncident pas avec le trajet de la folie, est-ce
un chant qui incline le  âme à construire pour
cela, je sais que c'est celui qui a donné l'
ordre de tuer pour avoir crié sur
un jeune en train de lécher ce top 8
joueur de billard enveloppé tout essaie de casser M.
a été battu par les garçons le lendemain ouais je vais me
battre un  repérer une fois de plus dur je
photos par les mots de la colline du trol  l
la réponse aurait dû être connue
du fonctionnaire soviétique Suleiman macho de su
donc fadama ne fait pas un double album Delaney sur
Shelby aviso para Randy Danny nah
militantisme a vu devaki